welcome everyone so excited you guys are
here we are going to be talking about t
driven development and we're going to
look at a cicd pipeline today um so
let's just go ahead and get started um
I'll just introduce myself real quick my
name is Liz I'm a full stack software
engineering consultant and so I've
worked on several projects that have
involved a large pipeline engines ETL
pipelines with extensive data analysis
I've worked with machine learning
engineers and data scientist to build
awesome products and I believe in test
driv and development to the extent that
it's almost exclusively how I work when
building applications I'm passionate
about learning new tools and
Technologies and using them for all the
things they
provide okay so if you guys want to
follow along in GitHub you can scan this
QR code and it'll give you a link to the
project in GitHub um there's a read me
to help you run it so anything that we
talked about today you guys will
hopefully be able to follow all the
steps but if not this is going to be
really good practice so we're going to
see um if you so you can scan that QR
code um there's also like links to
connect with me or other references that
I refer to during this talk um and then
we'll also put this up at the end if you
want to just grab at the
end okay so what are we going to do
today well we're going to be doing a lot
of things um we have a data set of
movies and we're going to build a simple
movie recomend based sentence and that
will be just kind of the first 10
minutes or so and we'll be working
primarily out of a compter notebook
while we build back once we finish the
notebook we'll know that we have
something that works and we'll know that
we need to how to prepare our data to be
used in our engine so then the rest of
the time we'll focus on productionizing
our data preparation scripts which will
involve the next four steps um we'll
pull the data preparation step from our
notebook and get them into a script
we'll pause on this for a bit while we
talk about how we can make our script
more modular and we'll add tests and
we'll talk about why we do
this then we'll have built these utility
modules we'll be packaging those all up
um and then we'll be utilizing GitHub
workflows to create a deployment
Pipeline and then we'll be shipping and
running our scripts and blue um so this
morning we're going to see it all the
way from the initial notebook to
actually being able to run it something
that could run in AWS this
morning
so um why are we doing this well I want
to provide an example of applying tdd to
large data Transformations because it'll
make testing like this feel more duable
in the future if it's something that you
want to do um when our code is less
prone to bugs or regressions because of
our tasks we'll save time and money in
the future and when we modularize our
scripts we'll enable future developers
to build quickly easily and with
confidence which will improve your
experience as we work together to build
awesome
products okay and we're going to do all
of that in 35 minutes which is now
probably 33 so let's go ahead and get
start it so we'll start with our like
initial data analysis which you guys
have probably all done before um but
what we're going to do is we're going to
pull a data set of movies from kaggle so
this data set that we're going to be
using I kind of modified it so I can
prove some points here but it's has
40,000 movies with um a genre like there
genres in one col
I'm just going to talk through really
quick what you're going to see in the
notebook because we're going to kind of
move through it pretty fast the genre
column is a pipe separated list of
genres for the movies what we're going
to do is we're going to in a several
different steps we're going to transform
that pipe separated list of genres into
just like a string of genres as if they
were the description of the movie We're
then going to use tfidf to create um
Vector representations of those
descriptions and then we'll compare
compare the movies to each other using
coine similarity um to so that we can
find movies with the most similar
description so the movies most similar
in content um so I'm actually going to
pause this part and we're just going to
jump into the Jupiter notebook now and
it's going to take just like 10 more
seconds than you would hope it would to
bring up the
notebook okay great
okay so um all right so we'll go ahead
and just in here it's going to take
myter I get the catch out we'll run the
first box and then we'll look at our
data and then we'll look at it shape and
again we'll just give it a second to
kind of catch up here um but basically
what we're going to be doing is we're
going to be looking at this data frame
okay here it is um you can see when you
first look at it that these genres are
all different cased um and there could
be like leading and trailing spaces on
that genres column so we're going to
have to clean that up and then we're
also going to want to remove any rows
that have this no genres listed category
this is sort of like a miscellaneous
bucket and if we were to group all those
movies together and start recommending
movies that way users would get um
movies that probably aren't actually
unrelated okay so the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to
um apply a function called lowercase and
strip spaces to our genres called column
for every row so that'll kind of clean
up that gen row just a little bit um
we're going to write a function to do
this like I just mentioned and we're
just going to do it in our notebook
first and then we'll go over into like
our actual code and implement it there
in like some sort of utility module that
we can just
import so here I have defined our
function and I have like the notebook
version here and then before we actually
use it I'm going to actually propose
that we test it and here's why we're
going to be running this function on
40,000 rows of data so we want to be
sure that it's accurate we're obviously
going to inspect the result of running
this function um but inspection doesn't
always catch everything so unit test
will fill in some of the gaps that
inspection would leave the other thing
is that we are going um this function is
really simple so we could probably write
it correctly the first time but if this
function is slightly more complicated
our unit test would give us faster
feedback while we iterate towards the
proper implementation of the function
and then finally when we pull this
function into a utility module and use
that in a script we'll know that c these
different pieces of our preparation
script are well tested and that will
prevent regressions in the future so I'm
going to go ahead and Define these three
test cases this is what we're going to
use and then I write this small test
function here you can see that this test
function is just running our function
that we're going to write on our input
and asserting that it's equal to your
expected output so now I'm going to run
our test before we actually implement
the function because and we want to see
that our test actually fail first um a
test that always passes is actually
probably not a good test because um if
these tests were to pass and this was
the implementation of our function we
would know that we actually have a
problem with our tests so we want to see
our test fail and we actually want to
see our tests fail in the way we expect
them to fail
um so that we know that they're testing
the right thing so now that those are
passing um I can just implement this
function for
us okay and then we can go back down to
our test boxes and run those again and
those all look good um so now we'll
actually go ahead and go into our code
and you can look at the way the unit
test looks for something like this so on
the right hand side I'm using this um p
has parameterized annotation and you can
see that it's basically doing the exact
same thing we just saw in our notebook
these this annotation is really useful
if we are have the same test logic but
we have one to run it on like different
scenarios different inputs and outputs
and so that's what we're doing here and
so similarly if we wanted to run these
tests I think I can just
oh uh run
this um and hopefully it won't take too
long we'll go ahead and see them fail
and we can also see why they're failing
a little bit better here we have our
expect our actual value and then our
expected value is different so now we
can go in here and we can just go
Um
here and then we can say input
lower and then save that and then we'll
go back to our terminal we give a test
again and hopefully we'll see it passing
and we are that's great so now we'll go
back into our notebook we'll app this
function that we are pulling in with our
Imports and then we'll go back down that
okay great we'll go back down here we'll
sample that just to make sure it looks
okay we still have this no gen's listed
category in there so we're going to go
ahead and remove that right here with
this line this giant box the short
version of what happens in here is that
we realize that we have movies that are
duplicated by title but some sometimes
their genre lists are different and so
what this box will produce is a list of
all the movies where that happens um
we're going to go ahead and just look at
one of those examples so you can see
here something like Aladdin the genre
the genre columns almost exactly it's
the same except for the very end one has
Musical and one has fantasy so we need
to clean this up as well um we're going
to do this in a few steps but the end
goal is that we have one Aladdin in our
data frame or data set it has all the
genres represented once and they're
separated by spaces so first what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to combine
group those columns and I'm going to put
um the genre strings into a list this is
running a little slow um so hopefully
it'll catch up um okay so now that we
have this list of genre strings we're
actually going to write another cleaning
function we're going to test that one as
well called combining genra list so you
can see I'm doing something very similar
here um I have two strings crime drama
four and crime drama action and I expect
a set that's what we're going to put put
it into a set first of prime drama or an
action and so if we go um ahead and run
this you say test combine and what I'm
running here is just way from the
command line if you want to run one test
file at a time and then it's going to
filter on the name so I just have to put
a name of the test that will pick it up
okay cool cool and then
here I can um go ahead and just
implement this function so I'll say all
genas is just an empty set and then for
the genre string and input we will
say string that split on
pip and then for genre in
genres we go ahead
add
it and then we
it and hopefully I
didn't
tests
okay great okay so those worked um which
is fantastic um so we're just going to
run this function and we'll just keep
moving here um I'm going to run the next
couple boxes get those going so
basically what we do then is we just
join them with the space um when we put
our U when we use the TF ID factorizing
we're going to need a list of all the
words in our Gus all the possible genres
so we're going to have to get that
string with this box um I think I just
show how many movies we have last year
3,000 um we'll run the vectorizer the
cosine similarity Matrix and this last
box really quick those are going to run
for a little bit and so I'm going to
talk about this get similar movies
function for a second um so the get
similar movies um function is going to
take in a movie title our cosine
similarity Matrix our um final data
frame and then we're asking for 20
movies but this function does have a
decent amount of logic in it and so we
are definitely going to want to also
test this one as well and so if I come
over here I'm going to say
recomendation um I'll open the test for
that on the right and then on this side
I'm going to go ahead and open a couple
test fixtures um
similarity Matrix fixture and then on
the bottom or I'll just put on the top
we'll do um what does this say movies
texture Okay cool so what we're doing
here is on lines 11 and 12 I'm importing
um these little fixtures files so if we
had this like somewhat complicated logic
and we were trying to figure out with
those giant data sets if this is correct
that would take a really long time it's
going to take a long time for them to
run and it's more error around um but if
we make those two pieces of data smaller
and with these fixtures we know exactly
what to expect and we can actually craft
them so that they'll test the different
pieces of logic in our code um so in
this situation this is like our many
similarity Matrix this is our data frame
if we're looking for the two most
similar movies to title one we should
get back title three and title four in
that order and for title two we would
get title four and Title One in that
order and so um we can go ahead and in
here we can run just see if I have it in
here yeah we'll run this file and um
we'll make sure that when we use those
fixtures that everything is
passing just take a second it's also
running something else okay perfect
let's go back to our notebook and see if
those things finished they are still
running um I'm just going to let them do
their thing because um my computer's
struggling a little bit but if you take
um one thing to note here is that if we
do when we run this and maybe we'll get
to see it at the end what we're going to
get is a bunch of kids movies that have
like action in them um so that's
probably accurate and we can see that
there I'm actually going to terminate
these boxes can cause me any problems
and we'll just close this and then we
can go back to our
presentation um I'm also going to kill
this guy he working pretty
hard yes
please all
right that was a lot
um back
here um that was a lot but hopefully
that stuff was like somewhat familiar to
you guys um if not again that's all
GitHub and so that you guys can go in
and run all that if you want um and ling
a sec to come
back okay let
back okay good we're
here okay so um let's go ahead and now
we're going to look at our preparation
script so um now that we have a notebook
of code that works we'll be moving on to
extracting a data preparation script
from our notebook this script can be run
on a schedule or on whatever um
additional other additional data that we
get to clean it and prepare it for our
engine so if we just copy and paste the
code from our notebook we're going to
get something that looks like this this
of course is a conted and fairly simple
example if you spent time pulling code
from notebooks into Data preparation
scripts then you probably look at this
code and think it looks pretty T you've
probably seen a lot of scripts that look
a lot more like this so this could be
okay as long as no one touches it or
they're really careful when they
do but spoiler alert someone is going to
have to touch it if I'm the engineer
coming into modify script like this I
find that I get the same sinking feeling
I get when I'm upstairs wrapped up in
something and my 5-year-old shouts up to
me saying that he wants milk but since
I'm busy he'll go ahead and pour it for
himself he may be able to pour it and
then I get to stay up here and continue
on the chore or task that I so
desperately need to finish but the
problem is if he doesn't successfully
lift the gallon jug up to eye level and
pour the sticky liquid into the small
siy cup I'll have a much larger mess it
similarly we can proceed now without
spending extra time to make sure that
this script is manageable to edit and
validate changes in the future we can go
on with our very busy days and get all
the things done that we so desperately
need finish but if we pause for a minute
here we may to be able to prevent huge
sticky messes that our future cell would
otherwise need to deal
with so why do we modularize this future
Engineers can understand it one piece at
a time testing each module will prevent
regressions in Behavior and the modules
will be reliably reduced so that'll also
save us time in the future if we can
find a use for them so here are the
lines from our preparation script that
fix the genres column
we can extract the part of our code that
starts with a raw data frame pulled from
our initial CSV and then produces a
clean data frame ready for our pit learn
libraries our function will look
something like this it can take in a
data frame and produce a clean data
frame and inside are all the steps that
we took to D records remove no genres
listed rows and produce a clean genre
description for the
movie okay so this is what our test is
going to look like um we'll be using
fixtures again and you see those on
lines five and six
here these um lines are where we import
the test files that we build in um order
to test various scenarios we've seen
fixtures already but it's important us
to think about how we build our fixtures
in each case in this case um this is our
initial data fixture um it's just a mini
representation of what our initial
unclean input data looks like and we use
our Aladdin example that I just pulled
directly from our data and then we also
use this scenario where the movie was
missing at
genre the other rows are other scenarios
we may have encountered one situation
where the no genres listed had leading
and trailing spaces finally we have one
that where there were three copies of
the same movie each with a different
genre when these rows go through our
prepare genres function we should see um
what we see here so this is our expected
output we've dropped the movies without
genres and combined properly the ones
that do have that
so in our test we have two assertions at
the bottom so we'll zoom into those one
of the assertions is that the number of
rows of the actual data frame the result
of running our initial data through a
function is equal to the number of rows
of our expected data frame the other
validates that the genre description of
the rows in the actual data frame
matches the genres of the expected data
frame this one is a little tricky
because we don't actually care about the
order of the genres in we actually care
about the content but when we put them
those genres into a set and compare the
two sets we see that it can handle our
data just fine and now that we have
fixtures it's easy to build on the code
we have in this prepare genre function
so let's say that we um have another
data set and in that data set there's a
situation where the genre column can be
empty so we can see pretty quickly if
that will work in our cleaning module we
can just add this last situation um to
our
CSV and when we run our Tas this data um
would actually break in a lot of places
um actually more than expected but we
can go through and update those broken
pieces one at a
time so two other benefits of testing
first is that they provide context on
what the code was intended to handle and
how it was supposed to be used this is
incredibly helpful to developers coming
into new code bases while tested codes
that has readable test cases is easier
for me to understand because I can read
the test to understand what the
developers hoped the code would do and
we can also Reactor with confidence so
while we were going through the notebook
if you thought like wow she's taking a
lot of separate steps to clean that
genre's called I could probably do it in
one L of code you could do that now you
can make that refactor and you can run
your test to validate that everything is
working the way you expect it
to Okay so now we can look at our script
again and substitute in our new
functions for the code that they have
inside of them so we'll zoom in there um
here we call our prepared gen function
that we just talked about and then here
we call another function we created that
captures the full genre list um and
that's just one I made up really okay so
most of what we leave in here is
interactions with S3 and where we're
just invoking Library functions and it
looks better and if we do this often our
scripts will remain reasonable size of
pieces that can be understood one at a
time okay great so it's really good to
pause on stuff like that it's um great
that Jupiter notebooks can give you easy
feedback on your code the way that it
does but we don't necessarily want its
feedback to replace good testing
practices um and so by breaking the code
into smaller pieces right away we set up
good patterns for the future that are
scalable now that we have a great set of
well tested utility utility functions
let's make sure we pack them up so that
they can be deployed and
used okay so why are we going to do this
next section well when we push our
prepare script to AWS blue it needs to
have these modules available our prepare
script relies on the modules that we
just created um so we'll package our
util module and then push it to S3 to
make it available to our blue
job to to package up our modules we're
going to be using a tool called poetry
um there's a number of options um for
packaging up modules like this but I've
really enjoyed using poetry it's a tool
for both packaging and dependency
management but today we're mostly using
it focusing on like the packaging part
of
it okay because we already have our
module built out we need to take our
existing project and initialize it with
poetry to do that we can do something
like run this command this poetry and
nit command um so and having this on
GitHub and me the file structure is
probably going to be helpful if you're
trying to like walk through this um
because I don't our modules are sort of
nested within our project so if you're
reading through the Poetry docs and you
it talks about the root of your project
here utils is going to act as like our
root um in terms of
packaging okay so after we run that AIT
command we'll now see a pie project
tomel file that you can see oh no it's
almost off the screen but it's all the
way down the
bottom um um a p project Tomo file is a
configuration file used in Python
projects to specify various project
settings dependencies and build
tools um okay so if we look inside this
is what it looks like it will have the
name of your package which is important
because this is the name you'll use to
import with so make sure you use the
name that you like and then some basic
information about the package so there's
two things that I want to point out
here um the the first one of those is
the python version and I call it out
because it caused me pain and I really
don't want it to cause you pain um AWS
glue jobs only go up to python
39 even though you the latest python
version is 312 so you can set the python
version something higher than 39 and it
could actually work just fine on your
machine but it will not work in AWS at
least for the python shell jobs so
you're going to want to pay attention to
the python versions and for AWS blue
python shell jobs set it to 39 or left I
think all those would dos jobs but it
would be okay the second one actually
say didn't cause me that much pain
because it's explained in the docs and I
love docs but this is where you would
put dependencies that your module needs
our prepared genres function is a part
of the module that we just packaged and
that function relies on pandas and so
we're going to need to include pandas in
our dependency list here I would also
recommend developing your project in a
python virtual environment that uses
like the same python version that you
put here so that your dependencies um
can kind of line up
properly okay so now that we have that
file all configured properly we can just
go ahead into our rout again and run
poetry build and the result of that will
be it will produce two files in a dis
directory at again the root of your
package one of them is a ZIP file and
then we have a wheel file o put that a
little fast
okay great so we have inspected we've
analyzed we've prepared our data we have
tested and modularized our preparation
script and we've packaged it all up so
now it's time to put this all into a
pipeline okay so first let's take a
second and talk about what our pipeline
will need to do first it will need to
build our package because our script
again needs our utility package to run
so if it doesn't build we may not even
we probably don't even need to bother
with the tests just yet but if it does
build we'll need to run our tests this
will validate that our package is good
to go then we'll push our prepare script
and our utility wheel to S3 where our aw
glue job can pick those things up in
order to actually do our data
preparation so we're going to be running
this pipeline in GitHub two minutes left
wait I started at
1010 so that's
28 weird that okay so we'll first take a
look at dependent workflows and and then
we'll take a look at reusable
workflows so first I'm going to explain
some of the basics about GitHub
workflows before we get too deep into
them um in case anyone hasn't worked
with them
expensively um workflows are configured
with yaml files and a simple workflow
configuration will something like what
you see here this workflow is named test
it will run on poll requests and the
simple way to explain that is that if
you open a poll request from a branch
against main it'll run on the merge of
the branch and Main together so it'll
like run tests on the results of that
merge um GitHub workflows or actions run
on GitHub machine so you'll see here
that we declare the jobs that we want to
run this workflow that we want this
workflow to
run um we'll tell it to use the latest
ubu distribution of linux's operating
system and then these uses tabs um are
just scripts that will set up that
machine for us and then we also will
have to run the last two commands at the
bottom which will um install our
dependencies and then actually run P
test if P test returns a nonzero exit
code this workflow will fail and githe
will let us
know okay so that's one small workflow
but just like we mentioned we want our
workflow to not just do one thing but we
want it to do three things ultimately we
will have a workflow that looks sort of
like this we'll build if build passes we
will test if test passes we will
upload okay so this is a little small
but um we are going to look at dependent
workflows um so this can be achieved by
using this needs tag which is getting
pointed to here um you can see here that
we've changed these steps together so
our publish step needs the test step to
pass before it will run test is declared
right before it and the test step needs
the build step to pass before it will
run that's how that
looks so this is fine um but the
pipeline that we have here would likely
only run on push this to main even
though I know it has P requests up there
but that was for test
if we open a PR to change our utility
module we want the first two steps to
run on PRS most likely but not the third
um and so in order to achieve that um we
would have to have separate triggers for
those two things we would basically copy
and paste those first two steps into
another file that would be run on poll
requests and then this whole file would
be run on merges to main um but just
like it was good to modular modularize
our script to make certain pieces
reusable it would be great if we could
have GitHub workflows that are modular
and reusable to avoid the problems that
come with copy and
pasting um and it turns out that the
wonderful people at GitHub have thought
of this and we can break each piece into
its own gamble file so this is our build
gamble file and the one thing I want to
call it here is that P tag on workflow
call Will Allow this action to be called
from another action
invoked by another action so this is the
first example where we see it we can see
um the test this is our test we can see
that we have a build step but instead of
copy and pasting the code from the file
we just saw we just give it the file
path to that build
utility um we still have our needs tag
and then that uses tag will um pull in
the other file so now the tasks depend
on successful completion of the build
step and the build step doesn't have to
be copy paste
it and then our prepare script will work
similarly we have the needs test test
pulls in the test Gamel that we
reference um and so all these three
steps will get changed
together okay so this is what will look
like when it's running in GitHub you see
the in that top picture that the um two
steps on the right are just kind of
waiting for the build set before they
start um one picture down the first two
steps have pass so upload goes go ahead
and tries to upload our files to
S3 if everything works everything's
passing you get all green and then in
the bottom one if something were to fail
the last the steps that depend on it are
marked as skip so here our test fail so
upload is skipped we don't
upload Okay so we've done a lot and we
almost have all the pieces in place the
last thing I want to make sure we cover
is create our AWS blue job this blue job
will run our preparation script either
on demand or on like whatever schedule
we
choose okay so what resources does our
glue job need it'll need our input data
um our preparation script and then we'll
need our modules those will all need to
be in
S3 in our case um this was done either
by our deployment pipeline or we'll be
done with separate scripts so if you're
pulling in data from somewhere you could
have a script that just gets the raw
data into the right
spot okay so we're going to be looking
at the terraform that will build our
glue job um you guys are probably
familiar with tform but if you're not
it's just an infrastructure code tool
that lets you build change and version
infrastructure safely and with careform
we can configure our S3 buets and a GL
do and code so we can provision our
resources in a way that's repeatable and
you can capture any updates or changes
you need to make inversion control which
is AES
okay so this is where the terraform will
look specifically for the blue job the
terraform that you guys that if you see
it on GitHub it'll actually have a bunch
of resources inside it one of the really
important ones will be um the roles that
we've configured to let our glue job
access S3 we're just not going to go
into that right now um we're just going
to focus on the glue job itself um if
you're familiar with
AWS um you can see that this is just a
way to create AWS Resources with codes
so instead of selecting drop down
options or filling in boxes we just
specify the key value pairs right
here okay so two things um again that I
want to point out like if we zoom in on
a couple spots we're specifying the
location of the script that our glue job
will use that's that script location
value and then we're also specifying the
python version that I mentioned when we
were talking about our poetry
package go over okay so this is also
really important so default argument
section we have a couple of very
important things the temp directory will
use to write temporary files during our
script execution this extra P files
argument will actually be the key to
allow our script to run at all um this
is where we'll put our wheel file that
was created when we pack just our
modules our prepare script relies on
this package and won't run without this
argument set properly also caused me a
lot of pain very important argument the
the library set is pretty cool that
analytics library has like there's a
full list of what it pulls in on the AWS
documentation but it pulls in things
like Panda and then specifically the one
we use is that library that we use to
interact with
S3 okay so then once we apply that we'll
have our glue job in a and we can run it
up in AWS um with a script or just the
button or whatever you guys want to
do okay so we did it um so just to go
over all the things we did and it was a
lot we did our data preparation we
extracted and modularized our prepare
script we practi our new modules we
built our Pipeline and we created our
glue job with paraform so that it's
ready to
run and that's all
[Applause]
so